kommen wir jetzt haben zu einer
nachricht die zdf zuschauer in ihrem
leben leider schon zu oft gehört haben
deutschland befindet sich im krieg meine
damen und herren handelskrieg donald
trump verhängt strafzölle auf stahl und
aluminium und nicht nur das er gestern
wörtlich gesagt wir deutschen hätten die
usa immer nur ausgenutzt
ökonomisch militärisch und sexuell
eins davon habe ich mir ausgedacht der
typ hat uns offen gedroht
und da wird diese was siegen
defizitzahlen haben werden wir das
regeln und wir werden das auch sehr
liebevolle weise sehr liebevolle weise
wie werden und mehr mögen als früher
er will uns liebevoll weh tun dafür zwar
auf der reeperbahn viel geld eine totale
schwachsinns aktion mit seinen zahlen
hilft er vielleicht zwei drei
stahlkonzern wenn überhaupt dann aber
alle andern us für alle andern us firmen
zahlen drauf weil ihre produkte teurer
werden das versteht doch eigentlich
jedes kind freihandel eine super sache
gut erzogene kinder tauschen waren und
dienstleistungen ein großer spaß von den
gigawatt bis das eine doofe kinder
zukommt das keinen bock mehr hat auf
freihandel weil es das prinzip nicht
[Applaus]
[Musik]
freihandel nichts für doofe
viele müssen wir gegen unseren
handelsüberschuss machen das ist richtig
und zur wahrheit gehört auch deutschland
und die eu sind in sachen freihandel
selber keine musterknaben
wir haben zb fette zölle auf
ausländische agrarprodukte um unsere
bauern zu schützen
dasselbe bei solarpanels es ist also
nicht nur trump der unter tollwut leidet
meine damen der präsident wird jetzt
heftig kritisiert sogar dass es
interessant von seiner eigenen partei
von den republikanern
nur sein handelsminister hat kein
problem mit strafzöllen auf metalle und
er erklärt ist wirklich sehr anschaulich
wie ken campbell soup company the coca
cola history center volumen diese
aluminium dose cola ist das einzige was
ich in meinem alter noch essen kann
meine damen barros ein multimillionär
erklärt den amerikanern das ist doch gar
nicht so schlimm ist wenn alles teurer
wird
und wenn sie jetzt sagen warte mal die
alte schildkröte kenne ich doch richtig
aus diesen berühmten gemälde sekunde so
wilbur ross hat echt ein topteam der
jump das allerdings täglich schrumpft
jetzt hat auch noch gary cohn gekündigt
sein bester wirtschaftsberater wohl
wegen der zelle aus dem weißen haus
strömt eine regelrechte fluchtwelle
könnte einem zu denken geben es sei denn
man heißt donald trump
das ist der beliebteste job überhaupt
direkt nach tester bei vw ist doch klar